[Música]
me pusieron después de un cantante un
delito olímpico a quien le rompo las
gaseosas pero bueno gracias por estar
acá no despertó un poquito
pacheco
soy abogado aunque no parezca estudié
derecho después de que me corrieron de
tres prepa si dos universidades estudia
derecho por las razones equivocadas
aunque la profesión la miro la respeto
mucho y digo por las razones equivocadas
por una razón lo peor que existe en este
mundo es la educación la forma
como se cómo se ejerce yo tengo un
severo índices de déficit de atención
entonces
me cuesta mucho concentrarme cuesta
mucho absorber información de la forma
tradicional como sucede no y peor aún en
un país como méxico que si el papá es
músico al hijito a los tres años la
vientre una guitarra o al del doctor le
avientan un microscopio siento que no
todos tienen la fortuna de encontrar lo
que realmente les apasiona
en grande en gran medida en etapa de la
etapa que se toma no por qué
porque la decisión más importante de tu
vida la toma en la etapa más pendeja de
tu vida los 18 años resulta que ya
tienes que saber si va a ser doctor si
va a ser músico iba a ser abogado o si
va a ser ingeniero a qué te vas a
dedicar y es todo eso le sumas la carga
la obligación que de cierta manera nos
impone la sociedad para seguir los pasos
de alguien y bueno en mi caso yo no yo
tuve una madurez emocional muy tarde
entonces pues estoy derecho porque media
para notario y estaba bien chido ser
notario no hay lana y no
entonces
y entonces pues por fin después de dos
universidades le quitarán la segunda
después de que me corrió de la primera
en un volado dijo cuándo voy a cabo
derecho me gradué de derecho empiezo a
trabajar la notaría
sin duda alguna es una profesión noble
es una profesión increíble pero que
requiere un mindset distinto que el que
yo tengo a mí me costaba muchísimo
trabajo
ejercerla como tal y me caso tengo tres
hijos son la parte más importante de mi
vida y como para los 35 años
dónde está
para los 35 años me doy cuenta que por
más ganas que le eches algo por más que
te esfuerces por más que estudies por
más que leas si no eres bueno para ello
yo me siento en ese piano días y días y
días y días nunca va a tener el talento
de que lo toca naturalmente no y a veces
peleamos mucho por por buscar hacerla
donde no debemos y estando ahí conozco
la gastronomía la comida empiezo a hacer
cenas en la notaría para traer gente
para traer clientes
empiezo a involucrarme mucho con la
escena gastronómica salir a catas de
vinos a
a todo lo que se podía y nace por ahí un
amor
a eso
me hago amigo de cocineros a los que
respeto muchísimo y una ocasión estando
en una en una comida en la fonda san
francisco que un favor alguien le puede
dar a hacer algo si me desvío quien
engaña porque realmente me voy a otros
lados pero bueno pensando en la comida
en la fondo san francisco con él o
correr a este wey que sale la tele de
masterchef llega a un chavo jaime luis
cantú
con hb que de hecho en su casa y yo de
la notaría con mi socio regalábamos vino
navidad a los clientes a los que
mandaban trabajo no entonces llega
no no no nada y yo para mí una cerveza
se hacía en una fábrica no era todo un
tema hacer la acumulación tu casa sé de
qué manera como en tu casa una cerveza
como cine si no estudiaste eso como si
no tienes equipo grande
y profesional por resulta que este güey
así hacer veces en su casa a la fecha y
ya tiene usted crecería y me encantó me
despertó el hecho de saber que alguien
tan común como tú puedes hacer algo
grandioso porque era una ciudad
increíble y marco que le dije oye y qué
pasa si si hacemos una semana juntos
para la navidad y esteve emisora le pues
va chingón dale
y ahí
empezó en mí una encontré y me encontré
este mucho puesto al explicar en el poco
tiempo que tenemos me encontré porque
empezamos yo quería poner regalarle a
mis amigos una cerveza que tuviera que
no dijeran los 3 104 horas o checo
entonces empezamos con la identidad de
la marca y le decía de la marca
nació tan de tan dentro de nosotros que
funcionaba perfectamente y que dice los
cuentos
queríamos que fuera
una imagen democrática porque les tengo
una noticia la cerveza la ves en el
estadio azteca y los retomando el dueño
de televisa y está tomando probablemente
un trabajador de la construcción y lo
mismo le da un mismo satisfacción es una
cosa universal entonces tenía que ser
algo universal tenía que no ser no ser
tenía que ser incluyente otro
valor que tiene que tener la coca cuando
fuimos con la chava que nos ayudó con el
branding llegue mi pregunta
para ti que es la cerveza toma cerveza
me dice entonces de un trago y le dije
pues es un premio y me dice que quiere
es premiar el esfuerzo y ningún premio
sintetizando lo porque creo que al final
de un día al final de un día de chambao
al final de algo cuando le echen muchas
ganas te quieres premiar con una charla
no una cerveza entonces queríamos que
fuera un premio al esfuerzo y de ahí
nace el nombre bocanegra por gonzález
bocanegra el creador del himno mexicano
que
qué
cuando cuando compone el himno fue a
través de un concurso que el gobierno
lanza gana en orán y el premio en el
conocimiento entonces esta marca nace
como un tributo al esfuerzo de los de
robar a las personas no estoy a saleh la
cerveza increíble salen a más una foto
en instagram benditas redes sociales que
te hacen enorme o quitas un pedazo común
y compadre
héctor negro
entonces
cuando cerveza la publica una revista en
londres y la madre y la sorpresa no
existía los bienes que ha salido y por
fin ya sale la cerveza para hablamos en
navidad y nos gusta tanto me gusta tanto
hacer eso que decimos oye y si vendemos
que tanto lo bueno vamos a darle mis mi
socio tiene restaurantes
yo tenía amigos que tienen restaurantes
y dije
tengo que la producción mínima que serán
500 cajas de 500 cajas 20 amigos son 25
al mes declaró way es una hora diaria
claro que tienen que ir no sido sorpresa
no fue así
y por fin empezamos a ahora sí a vender
la literal un cuarto en mi casa era la
bodega
la fabricamos en guadalajara y lo
increíble de todo esto es que
hoy en día sé que cualquier persona que
en una etapa muy importante cuando
empiezo yo con el bajo la tierra es
hermosa una botella que no tenía
etiqueta porque yo lo quería contaminar
el mundo no queremos queremos apoyar en
eso y me dice ah chingá si quebró
mauricio porque tú no lo haría si es un
empresario muy rico de monterrey que
tuvo sobre sí le quebró y a mí me enojo
me enojo muy cabrón porque yo dije se
supone que este güey media de apapachar
decir que es un chingón y que la voy a
romper porque me dice que voy a quebrar
no entonces dije ni madres hay que darle
hay que darle hay que darle tanto que
ahora llevo como bandera el el tema de
vito historia porque
en el proceso de de llevar a ser mosca
negra que vive toda clase de chiflidos y
mentadas de madre y el diablito
gutiérrez y dejarte mamá
el porta salar no vas a quebrar todas
las que seguramente todo mundo nos han
dicho no y pues bueno me cuelgo yo a mi
socio del del literal de la espalda y me
pongo a vender casa por casa lugar por
lugar nos abrimos muerte en méxico en
otras ciudades etcétera y al día de hoy
lo que más me gusta hacer sin duda es
llevarle al mundo
de la manera que antes no dos años
después como dice la presentación se nos
acerca el modelo grupo modelo y nos dice
oye pues me dice con perfecto tengo la
tenía la foto por ahora podemos poner
cuando nos dice el director el director
general es tú qué quiere hacer con
bocanegra dije me quiero chingar a
corona
hable a cambio de no quedar ahí pero
entonces se hace para atrás y me dice y
si lo hacemos juntos y a la madre acá
entonces ha sido un viaje increíble el
saber que un en su casa sin lana
otra sorpresa más corta la y no de la
narración nunca hecho una cerveza en mi
vida
yo la cerveza
tenemos gente que la hace no entonces lo
hermoso de esto es que creen puedes ser
lo que quieras con bien poquito sin
ningún problema no entonces bueno ya por
fin después de un año de negociaciones
con ellos y de ver cómo está la cosa
pues hoy bocanegra está compitiendo con
corona nueva york que los ángeles porque
corona no es de modelo ya
el grupo del cual es dueño modelo es
competencia de color en eeuu entonces
sigo después de esto
me encanta nos descubro que mi talento
realmente no ser abogado sino crear
cosas y empiezo a hacer algunas otras
cosas como tequila vinos
y restaurantes y creo que el mensaje que
les quiero dejar así fuerte fuerte
fuerte es las cosas
que más admiras de la vida sin duda
alguna las hizo a alguien
tan como tú entonces creo que
todo se puede
y gracias
[Aplausos]